what does the saying people watch people
first
mean oh i feel like i'm being quoted
back at myself
um because i say that all the time um
[Laughter]
someone really clever said that i don't
know who what now uh
the um i
this is because and i've and this is
from
love my mistakes right because i became
obsessed in making my own short films
about how everything looked
and it had to look good everything had
to look i had to have that camera if i
had to have that lens i had to have
that lighting and you sort of forget
that people watch people first like you
know there's no point
in going to all the effort and time and
money and emotion
everything making a film if your actors
are miscast
you know it's just it's pointless you
know you could have the best script in
the world
you could have chinatown but with really
horrible actors it'd be a horrible movie
you know whereas you know chinatown with
amazing actors
shot on a phone you know might be not
your cup of tea but it'd still be a good
movie right you know it's kind of
it's i feel like people they think
there's a few things i think
directors um can be quite scared of
actors
i think um because
i feel you have to really put yourself
out there emotionally for them to meet
you
where you need to be met you know and
that can be a scary thing for some
people or some people
like to hide behind the technical side
of things like hide behind the monitor
and um or maybe just enjoy
the technical side of it first but i
always say look if you don't love actors
and i love
actors right a lot of my friends are
actors
i could never do the job it's even
harder than what i do
um all that rejection and lack of
control
uh makes me sick thinking about it but
um i i you know
but i love them i love working with
actors it's it's a real joy
um if you're not that person then go be
a dp
or go direct you know coke cans and
commercials you know kind of thing
and the same way if you're into actors
you're not into camera
go direct theater i mean you've you've
you know i
i don't like this idea that oh you get
actors directors and you get technical
directors like
your job is to do both when you make a
film because it is a visual medium
as well as being a dramatic media in
terms of performance
so you have to and you may have
strengths and weaknesses in the both but
you can't just reject one
especially when it comes to performances
um
and if you don't agree with me
go next time you're on set or even just
you know go be an extra in something or
go and you know take part
go stand the other side of that camera
and know how it feels to be that alone
and wonder why you're not getting those
performances or you're not getting that
thing
that's coming across and being
frustrated because
you know you you can hide behind the
technical side whereas the actors really
can't
and they need a helping hand so
you really need to love the form and
understand the form
in order to get the best out of the
actors because
people watch people first you know it
you know i've sort of mediocre film with
amazing performances
will be a much better film than the
other way around um
and that that's what we go to films for
right is to experience
worlds and stories through other people
whether that's a green alien
or someone that looks like you you know
they're all characters it's all
we're looking we're searching for
emotional connection
um and um and that comes obviously from
the performance first and everything
else
helps that performance i feel that
when i uh i'm directing anything
whether it's a commercial something one
line or an emotional scene a film
i feel like oh what i'm doing is setting
the stage and
creating the environment for the actor
to do the best
job you know to be in that moment and be
in a safe space and feel supported
and that's and that's what's most
important
over knowing your lenses knowing what
your shot list is you know all that is
obviously important
but and maybe it comes with experience
maybe it comes with
knowing being on enough sets or knowing
the room but
i'm very protective of my actors like um
because i feel that they uh
their phones need to be respected like
my god if you are on your phone
on set when someone's acting uh i will
not be a happy bunny
you know it's just disrespectful um
and uh i know i'm um
uh i know i'm not alone in that and also
i know that people some people don't
care
but i just i just feel that that's what
you need to do
especially especially on your first
films
because and this is what i say about
if you're going to pay for your camera
pay for your actors because
you know if you can pay for your actors
maybe you can get into that agency or
get that casting directive that can get
that better actor
that is maybe a bit more experienced
than you but don't be intimidated
because they're going to make you
look way better than you are you know
um in what they do on screen and
and that's that's an asset and you
shouldn't be afraid of that you should
embrace it
as a director i know you've talked about
preparation
being very important for you what do you
do when an actor shows up
on set and they're not prepared
um what do i do i think
i mean there's a few things with that
maybe if they're not just if they're not
prepared
because they've just not learned lines
for example
they're obviously and you need to shoot
that scene there and then
you know you just get into very
practical things of
cue cards and boards and or maybe try
and shoot the other side
first so the actor gets into the flow
you know it becomes very practical and
it's um
not being prepared emotionally that's
that's trickier that feels like
that's part of my job to
have foreseen it you know
like the like there's an art to kind of
scheduling something where
on day one you're not going to do the
most
emotional performance because everyone's
flying their feet even the actors are
finding their feet in the role like
you're going to save that until
maybe the middle of the schedule when
everyone's not really tired you know
um so there's a real art that comes to
that um
so hopefully you've thought about that
or you
can have you know i like to
um talk to actors uh
either obviously every act is different
but on a feature
we'll maybe talk about what's i'm
expecting the next day to be
um and uh and if that's something that's
emotional i'll maybe just
plant a few seeds at the end of the day
um
so they can kind of be prepared when
they get there or i'll be there when
they as soon as they get to make up as
soon as they get to their trailer as
soon as they get
there to go okay today's a big day
what do you need you know how are you
feeling what because you don't know
someone could have and there's all the
unexpected stuff like someone could have
broken up with their girlfriend
that night you know and they turn up the
set and they're supposed to be this
big jovial happy scene and they're just
not in the mood like you know
um so you know a million things can
happen
but it's your it's your job to try
and um set the stage for them to
do the performance they need to do that
day and whether that
as i say it's a practical way of just
getting through the day
because they've had a few to drink last
night and not learn their minds
or or something more emotional it's kind
of your job to
to be prepared for that as a director
have you ever skimped on preparing for a
film and if so what happened
uh yeah i have actually um
and um
it was mainly it was so i did an indie
feature that was very kind of low budget
um and um i was
quite busy during prep and and it was
one of those where we didn't quite know
the money was gonna happen and then it
suddenly sort of happened and
i didn't really have a lot of time to
prep so
maybe i'm making excuses for not doing
the hard work
but i mean like i shot listed it and i
knew about it but i feel like
maybe from a script level um
i didn't live with it more maybe you
know i feel like
on reflection i've probably maybe missed
a few beats
that uh and i'm not talking huge things
like you know we
we i shot the film and we made it and it
works and we saw you know it's all that
but i think i think of him being very
critical of myself was that like
maybe not being completely intimate with
the material as much
as i wanted to and i think
um uh and i think maybe that was
a bit of a struggle on on the odd scene
that
maybe for some of the things we talked
about about
not preparing the stage more or maybe
thinking i needed less time to shoot
something that i actually did
you know or underestimating how long
action scenes take
to shoot sometimes and things like that
so um thing is i i do enjoy and thrive
on being um
i want to say under prepared but but
not being completely set in stone what's
going to happen
you know uh sometimes i feel like my
best work is
isn't is is in the um the spontaneity
um or or um
the you know like on you know exam a
case in point on star's origins
which i pre-vised and shot listed
and worked on for three years before i
got the shooter i know
knew every single frame of that what
that film was going to be
and then you get to set and then you
shoot in the desert and then your actors
get sick
and then you suddenly don't have the
actors that day that you need the actors
for
and then you have to come up with
creative ways of shooting the scene
based on what you have available and
piecing it together in a very different
way
that now you i see you see it and you go
actually that's probably better but but
um but that spontaneity has forced you
to be to think on your feet creatively
and come up with
uh a way of meeting the day a way of
meeting the schedule you know and making
things work
so um so yeah i think i mean less
lesson learned from maybe from that film
uh
but um you know i'll probably hold my
hands up
to a few things some of it was out of my
control in terms of scheduling not
prep time and stuff but i probably
should have maybe focused more on
um you know some
a particular character arc that maybe i
don't feel like i quite nailed
um versus
uh you know some of the other stuff you
know that that i had a limited time
you